هنا في تعز اليمنيه لا يسلم الاطفال من
رصاص قناصه ميليشيا الحوثي الذين يتمركزون
في الابنيه العاليه هذه الابنيه التي
انهكتها حرب لا تزال مستمره منذ نحو ثمان
سنوات
وكما كل الحروب يدفع المدنيون الثمن
الاغلى منها لاسيما الاطفال
لا نتركهمش يخرجوا هنا
حتى اذا في قضائها او شيء خروج الاطفال
للعب في الخارج في تعز يهدد حياتهم فاربعه
من اطفال فاطمه كانوا ضحايا قناصه ميليشيا
الحوثي وذنبهم كان انهم ارادوا اللعب
خارجا ذات يوم السبب الاطفال
حاولت الام المنكوبه توثيق ما حدث
لاطفالها على امل تحقيق العداله فيما
تستمر الحياه بظروفها القاسيه على اهل
مدينه تعز الذين بات بعضهم يختبئ في مباني
مهجوره خشيه ان تطالهم رصاصات الحوثي نور
الحصن العربيه